[Musique]
micheline elle a 30 ans au pacte en
buvaient pas classé
m
sont très différents des enfants les uns
des autres
je suis pas du tout les mêmes caractères
pas du tout je crois en dieu agrée cui
le troisième fils les amplis lobby s'en
mettraient métier on peut rien lui dire
qui se met à pleurer alors c'est très
désolant pour un garçon mon mari était
très très longtemps comme ça on peut
rien leur dire non
[Musique]
jean luc michaud le petit voyou mais la
traite très bon caractère
je voulu mettre une fessée dix minutes
après viendra m'embrasser le marché se
remet à neuf civils c'est un caractère
très très ken orange évite de la
brusquer
chanter avec très franchement c'est
l'ennui de bière du temps ça s'il va
venir et puis c'est fini
elles atteindront que pierre patat
monnaie
a son petit caractère enfin elle mettre
bien si je devais faire il le fait si
moi j'étais malade je la garer plus
facilement la maison à me rendre service
que les autres
daniel c'est un autre caractère et elle
est très exigeante et si elle a dit oui
c'est pas loin sans se faire traiter qu
ils ont tous leurs petits défauts mais
enfin vous étiez aussi que fameux très
nombreuses oreilles vous mes amis car on
sait rien
et je vous êtes allés à l'école jusqu'à
quel âge 14 sont ensuite je suis parti
deux ans dans une maison parce que ma
maman était bien malade
avec eux électricité de france à bure
ont été très bien d'ailleurs
donc ça m'a fait jusqu'à 16 ans d'école
mais je peux vous aviez décroché le
certificat d'études d'ailleurs son plus
bel mes petits frères 2010 heure j'ai
appris de bonnes choses de la coupure
très cool mais sa mort c'est par l'école
cette année
est-ce que j'ai quand même l'impression
savent m'enquiers urgemment beaucoup
même quand il faut écrire depuis que ce
soit les enfants qu'il faut qu'ils vont
mettre c'est pas toujours attrayantes
moi c'est l'orthographe je voudrais bien
mais chez bosch et l'orthographe sans
arrêt des fous
et après vous saison est revenu chez
votre mère votre maître a plongé été
placé comme boigny j'étais placé comme
bonne à la motte piquet grenelle chez
les américains ensuite j'ai quitté pour
l'usiné parce que j'étais pas bien payés
meilleur je suis pas resté l'auteur
qu'ensuite j'ai travaillé à levallois
dans les dans l'après-midi alors c'est
aussi dur c'était déjà beaucoup plus
loin fallait me lever à 5 heures tous
les jours
et à ce moment là vous avez rencontré
votre mari est ailleurs j'ai rencontré
mon mari sheila char où il travaille
parce que j'ai travaillé ce film j'ai
tué mon mari dans son travail
j'ai fréquenté 17 mois mais discrètement
et puis alors à brive on est tous les ce
tous les jours je voit désigner le soir
à lomé par l avais marre alors voyez
vous
[Applaudissements]
malema s'est mariée on avait dit ginette
on était jaune
nous avons eu patrick presque tout de
suite en 56 après nous avons gagné 1,57
chantal entre temps mon mari fait son
service militaire j'ai des pixels je
travaillerai chadema fils chez la mère
ou six
[Applaudissements]
tu vas voir
moi je vais faire quelque chose vous
avez commencé ce matin par quoi
commencer je commence
j'ai commencé par faire du café frais à
mon mari la firme avait ensuite le
déjeuner des enfants
ah oui votre lessive tout de suite fait
bouillir le temps que les enfants des
jeunes
ensuite le temps d habiller et puis
ensuite à jeunes je les amis je les ai
dit ali g prend 2,2 grâce à ça les a
obligés à genappe un email
alors vous savez mais sa vue c'est la
même chose
oui ma vie j'avais été plus ou moins
bien fait le boulot on dubai attache
avec le haut et attache avec robert
c'est quoi l'enjeu des habits consultés
ils ont déjoué pour parce que je le
remets leur maintenance et ce à partir à
l'école ils sont partis à l'école j'ai
fini mon lavage et puis je me suis mise
à laver les ball l'avait l'atlantique on
lit puis donner un pot à la salle est
alors c'est le petit gars passent en
dernier parce que comme c'est le dernier
relais c'est lui qui passe le dernier
après midi
l'après midi je bricole à la maison j'ai
beaucoup de choses le raccommodage là je
dois passage lavage manque toujours
quelque chose à tablier un mouton à
l'acte
on savait qu'il y avait 400 m où il
donne mais il faudra commander c'est
bien gentil de leur part ils se mettent
bien ça dépanne bien commun
à l'écouter indiquant oui qu'est-ce
qu'on vous reposer pour d'autres
personnes ici je crois pas ces jeux là
je pourrai pas tiré la semaine 126
salaire au bras côté au premier jeu le
pack naissance entraîne la cour
confirmant alors c'est pour ça me permet
de payer patronage aux lèvres la villa
parce que beaucoup d'enfants de
l'immeuble se retrouvent de la cour oui
et puis alors il ya des bêtises de ce
fait il ya dix carreaux cassés ou lors
des zaïrois vrai légaux soit vers
servait le haut comme ça je sais me sow
ils partent le matin 8h30 ils reviennent
le soir à 6h après c'est la toilette
lors pas accouché alors comme ça il faut
pas de bêtises et ça leur plaît beaucoup
sa lampe led ailleurs l'activité a très
bien la natation là dedans cela nous
amène beaucoup beaucoup de choses
seulement je les ai pas mis quelques
jours dit se servir chez genêt quatre
qui vont 310 francs par an je dis ça
c'est très cher comme ces moments des
châtaignes ou châtaignes
ils vont muguet ils vont chercher des
gens qui ont mis fin de belle chose que
vous aviez plus du temple moyens ce que
vous aimeriez vous occuper de nos
vêtements de votre toilette ou pas du
tout vous êtes cela intéresse pas nos
joueurs que je suis propre sort avec mes
enfants pour que je vais quelque part et
vous ne devez jamais d'aucun produit
doté de normes un démaquillant mon mari
a horreur des serres c'est une perte
d'argent et vous les désapprouver chez
les autres modes non non non pas du tout
j'estime qu'une petite chaîne fille ou
une jeune femme qui est bien maquillé
comme trouve seulement quand on la
disait simplement manger parce qu'en
première
mais si charest tomari tous les deux ça
nous arrive de temps en tabagisme avec
ça un âge mais un petit peu trop
j'allais être plus en plus ça si je veux
bien j'aimerais bien le coiffeur dessus
comme beaucoup seulement celle-ci
croissant du coiffeur sur une semaine
comme sur tout mais qu'est ce qui reste
pour manger les enfants regardent mais
du bout des doigts c'est pas mon éthique
nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon bah les moins chers à l'achat
je suis un bon petit le jour je crois
vous percevez votre salaire et comment
organiser pour votre budget quand vous
arrivez à chaque semaine j'ai décidé la
façon d'organiser votre budget pour la
semaine par mois je les affaires de ma
femme du budget madame edel est ce que
vous vous organisez sur le mois ou
plutôt sur la semaine et non sur la
semaine pour chaque domaine de la
semaine c'est ce qu'on peut pas
s'organiser sur moi pendant deux mois je
m'organise qu'avec la paye de mon mari
la pièce sert pour le loyer pour les
pauvres à la les allocations familiales
salaire pour le loyer le gaz
si j'ai acheté un meuble à créditer des
maîtresses c'est cela et l'ansej sert
uniquement pour le ménage sa nourriture
n'est pour la nourriture les vêtements
des enfants produits d'entretien et lui
ma copine des enfants de chaque semaine
c'est ça mais par exemple vous disiez
que vous n'arriviez pas tellement les
gens qui achetaient des voitures à
crédit et se privaient de tous pour
acheter des voitures l'euro moi je sais
que pour ma part moi j'aimerais pas
faire un crédit pour une voiture sachant
que j'ai pas de quoi nourrir mais sans
fin et vous vous estimez qu'il ya des
personnes qui le font oui certainement
parce que vous savez quand on a 5 6
enfants et qu'on a une voiture et un
seul salaire je suppose que fout
vraiment préparé gagnent beaucoup moins
entretenir la voiture et les enfants
sages
pour gueye a joint sa mairie le samedi
matin
belval je me lève à 4 heures mon mari
étant là j'en profite pour aller faire
mes courses pour la semaine pour avoir
mangé pour les enfants pour aller
jusqu'à 120 je prends le métro jusqu'à
retenir échanges
la première action légale
direction porte en lui
ça m'ennuie pas du tout puis j'y
retrouve quand même à la fin de la
semaine aux bénéfices ça change un petit
peu des marchés les marchés c'est
toujours un sourire tu as dit que si
vous à nouveau al c'est plus du tout la
même ambiance
ça crie ça rouspète ça se défend quoi
une sortie une distraction une fois par
semaine vous paraissez la pêche mondiale
[Applaudissements]
je vous dis tata où est maman qu'est le
déni imagine mal aux oreilles je peux
servir sur le balcon
la bamboo lancé beaucoup de température
40 à 3 heures ce matin à 6h40 et vous
êtes levés quand même cela mais l'image
pour les enfants lp la toilette
d'exemple déjeuner mais vous n'avez pas
comme vous le savez pas quoi il avait
commencé mais pas moins qu'après le
petit moi j'ai les jambes comme du coton
alors je préfère rester chez moi quelque
chose mais ça ne s'arrête pas
c'est pas que ça m'arrête pas il faut
pas mal fait par les huit ans ces cas
viennent manger et comme déjà précisé si
vous étiez bachelot donnera une autre
filiale ge était sérieusement malades
jeunes envers une aide familiale par la
caisse des annotations papa une voisine
un homme non je préfère que la caisse
membres quelques arrêts tout payer le
mini gamme à quelqu'un puisque c'est
comme ça je voulais être familial
devrait pas beaucoup tourné mais on fera
si vous avez d'ailleurs voyez je suis
parti en clinique j'avais tous mes
enfants j'ai dit deux mais une dame âgée
ici juste pour l'heure le soir pour
l'heure pas du sien c'est tout et puis
j'en ai donné du hamas heures le comité
presse m
voilà c'était encore dans la bouche pas
non pourrais tu pleurais c'est mon papa
était de chercher
ouais je t'avais dit que j'avais pas de
chercher aujourd'hui que j'étais malade
alors il va plus aller trop loin ça
qu'est ce que tu as fait à l'école j'ai
une partie de mes pairs aujourd'hui
l'esthétique est fort n'est pas bien
mais j'avais peur aujourd'hui elle
fatiguée c'est un gym c'est parce que
les marais sa première fois on prenait
un projet voiture attend les enfants
quelle est l'origine talal d orange a
vraiment haussé mon jeu n'est ce pas la
vocation
et après que l'hélicoptère ça ça dérange
votre votre journée habituelle quand si
elle est malade
enfin comme serré sur ton sort de la
tente vraiment un jour on s'y fait
progresser vraiment prêt j'ai regardé la
maison est ce que pour vos filles vous
souhaiteriez une vie semblable à la
vôtre c'est à dire avec beaucoup
d'enfants et le même genre de vie non
non je m'en veux j'aimerais par contre
que mes enfants viennent le dire plus
tard bon je n'aime pas les enfants non
ce serait l'agriculteur d'entre eux
vision vous attacher beaucoup
d'importance à leur vie scolaire j'aime
pas qu'ils manquent l'école les
apprenait japon provient alors s'y moque
elle qui paie son verre vous aimeriez
les voir pousser leurs études autant que
possible les appelle un métier qui se
voit pas dans l'ignorance
autant beaucoup retiendront qu'elles
soient pas des ignorants pas parce que
moi je n'ai pas pu apprendre qu'il faut
pas se permettre à mes enfants
d'apprendre
bon je vous dis moi il ya beaucoup de
choses qui me manquent pas que je
voudrais bien ré apprendre que cieux il
est tel que les gens de la terre et mer
c'est eux qui me reprendrai ne rompt pas
aller à l'usiné où est boniche comment
j'étais ciseaux une éducation aux cylons
leur certificat d'études que moi je n'ai
pas ça je n'y ai pas de ça ici je peux
travailler pour leur donner une
éducation ce qui leur faut j'ai fait moi
je suis pas malheureuse mon mari et moi
pendant leurs oeufs pas du tout pour
traire il est très courageuse avec tout
ce qu'il a eu seulement ce qui est
beaucoup trop de travail
quand on peut pas se permettre d'avoir
le pansement d'avoir tant d'enfants
malgré que les aime bien la même réunion
je les mettrai à la page moi j'ai pas
été mise à la page en étant jeune si au
moins il était d'une famille très
nombreuse et je mettrai mes enfants
l'apache les qui seront en âge ça de
façon que de s'asseoir à skis choisir
librement le nombre d'enfants que
désigne le voir vous même si vous
n'aviez pas dû subir cette opération
on ne riait consulter le planning à ouïr
du ring pour la santé mon mari savez
c'était pas le payer alors des enfants
tous les hommes sont bien millions 35
amen à l'église de koné et twitter
souvent et avant d'avoir la télé qu'est
ce que c'est les dimanches mois le
dimanche pour mes chansons je leur dit
d'aller au parc de la mairie ou parkas
colombe je suis pour dix craint pour les
enfants je suis très fier sortir avec
eux d'ailleurs très mignon tu fais ma
petite journée comme d'habitude mon
ménage si jeune et si je la fais je
raccommodage un fait et je regarde la
télé
samedi stremme qui peut d'ailleurs moi
j'aime bien les émissions et igor
barrère et kendall ou sur la médecine
c'est la chirurgie se mettent beaucoup
j'aime bien ça je regarde ça d'ailleurs
j'en rate jamais une de ses émissions
et vous trouvez que ça vous cultive que
ça vous instruis très très bien
d'ailleurs mon mari ruche peut être
parce que c'est très tard le soir alors
oui trop fatigué pour si tu veux
construire sa achètent des livres de
médecine et puis tu auras toujours la
même c'est peut-être un peu ingrat quand
même mais c'est pas la même chose déjà
même un livre fouillé pas l'image tu
habites là vous voyez l'image si vous
avez envie de voir une opération moi
j'ai toujours rêvé de voir une opération
lui il aime la pêche moi j'aime la pêche
mais je peux pas y aller je me vois pas
la pêche avec six enfants
alors il va tout seul devant le jld à la
pêche tout seul bon ben si aux vacances
on est tous les deux avec un petit 1.6
bliard le petit puis murray ce péché en
somme vous n'êtes jamais ensemble ça non
mais jamais selon sont jamais et ça
cette charmante et j'ai l'impression
qu'elle se fatiguent beaucoup c'est le
bruit
j'aime bien dans le calme j'aime bien
tout seul avec les lois c'est difficile
temps idéal pour l usine ya le bois à la
maison est toujours du bruit y'a qu'la
que je vais à la pêche n'a vraiment je
sens que la tête ça commence à revenir
j'arrive à récupérer bien donc vous ne
poser quelques questions là enfin je
peux répondre tranquillement nos sens à
vraiment moche et fatigué c'est pas
possible je réponds comme ça dans le
vide mais je m'en rends compte que je
dis quand je m'en vais bien souvent ça
me fait mal au coeur de partir tout seul
il faut même difficile de faire
autrement avec les enfants pour les
emmener à la pêche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]